what's up guys bang-bang lunch money
time we're back in person me and the
beautiful intelligent play tamara nova
while while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right are you happy that I'm back
yes good answer
Paul Tudor Jones first topic what's
going on with the legend so Paul has
nearly 2 percent of his assets in
Bitcoin of all things Paul Tudor Jones
is a multi billionaire as we're about
five billion dollars he manages about
twenty two billion dollars at Tutor
investments he since literally the
mid-80s has been one of the best
investors in the entire world I started
to make Plano watch a documentary on him
very bad but the actual content very
good go on
it's the mid-80s what do you think they
didn't have iPhones they were not
tick-tock God so Paul Tudor Jones he
basically came out last week so that
he's got about these barring Bitcoin
he's actually not buying actual Bitcoin
he's getting exposure through the
derivatives market but he believes that
it is going to be a great hedge against
all of the inflation that is coming from
the printing of money and now he came
out this morning on CNBC said he's got
about two percent of his assets in it
which is somewhere between let's call it
three hundred to five hundred million
dollars now those are his personal
assets he's not investing his clients
money in it my guess is that he's
talking about the 22 billion that he
manages because what I believe he does
and don't wholly do this is that he
actually invests his money
alongside his clients so just be
managing his own money and then he has
client money that just goes in on top of
it well here's what he said that I
thought was interesting he said when I
think of Bitcoin look at it as one tiny
part of a portfolio it may end up being
the best performer of all of them I kind
of think it might I kind of think it
might be but I'm very conservative yeah
of course low key this the reason why is
a big deal is cuz he's not only won a
legend for past performs to is people
think that he's a very sound
decision-maker he's very intelligent
he's
we've done his work and one interesting
tidbit is in 2017 he actually invested
in Bitcoin he doubled his money and then
he got out then was like oh I just
played the trend right like like this
big bull market I got in I got out no
problem
he's now revisited it and decided this
is a great inflation hedge he's got a
whole framework for how he did that but
it's a big deal that he's publicly
saying this right whether printing
trillions about I always love to see him
and mr. wonderful one-on-one talk about
Bitcoin it would be a bloodbath it'd be
so funny well because because I feel
like Paul Tudor Jones is so logical and
like rooted in reality and then mr.
Wonderful's like this is trash garbage
take it out one of them is a very
disciplined Wall Street investor the
other is an entertainer that's Jim
Wright and Kevin earlier by the way is a
good investor as well but he's but he
simply he understands when he's on
camera that he's supposed to entertain
and that's why he does it okay
never forget that he forbid me from from
doing what I've done it's all right on
national television if I said I forbid
you from something I would just go do it
alright Bitcoin having happy having day
there's like there's a couple of days a
year that are important every four years
there's like Christmas that's a big deal
every year there's Mother's Day that's a
big deal a Father's Day your birthday my
birthday and every four years there's
having day it's a happy having day all
right good
by the way fun fact when we were looking
at dates for our wedding I think this
was like around this time was one of the
proposed dates and he's like absolutely
not knows like why he was like it's
having day yeah you can't have your
wedding unhappy day would be crazy this
is an international holiday okay so the
Bitcoin having's happening today
it's got moved up a little bit it's
happening around three o'clock today and
we're gonna go from 1800 Bitcoin a day
to 900 on the incoming supply as people
know supply demand big deal he's having
a Bitcoin having party a virtual one and
I'm not really invited which I'm upset
about am I invited what are you gonna do
at the having livestream I'm gonna talk
to my friends plan is not ready for the
Bitcoin community
they're too ruthless all right so having
is happening today I expect it to be
somewhat of a non-event on the price
standpoint maybe we'll get a little drop
afterwards but we'll see what happens
but over the next 18 months
this is incredibly bullish so it's
happening today pay attention if you
want to learn more about it ask in the
comments of IU's question so we have it
not not we but like the people haven't
mined at the 21 million bitcoins it no
eighteen point three to eighteen point
four million somewhere in there have
been mined okay so that means that less
than 3 million are left to be mined yeah
so if they're all mined before the next
having will there be a next happy
they won't be oh why because we
programmatically know how many is the
beauty of Bitcoin is we don't know what
interest rate decisions are gonna be
next we don't know how much more money
the feds gonna print right I mean
literally there's I've got a four
stimulus right now we don't know how
much it is we don't know when it's gonna
happen
so everyone's speculating in the market
on whether it's gonna happen or not how
much it's gonna be it cetera
instead here I know exactly today at
around 3 o'clock we go from 1800 Bitcoin
a day to 900 that means that every 10
minutes we're gonna get 6.25 Bitcoin
that's gonna happen for four years then
it'll get cut from there in half again
for four years get cut in half again all
the way out and that'll take us to about
20 140 give or take until we run out of
Bitcoin to mine and then was 20 years to
mine all the remaining lesson 3 million
oh wow so we're not gonna be alive for
that I don't know about you but I plan
to be alone oh my god so crazy okay
would you get cryogenically frozen no
y-you don't want to come back
I just want to decompose like everybody
else really yeah no how would you come
back well if you get cryogenically
frozen and they have technology to bring
you back your mind your soul they can
download integers they can be downloaded
to cannot download my jokes back yes
they can
did you listen to the Joe Rogan Elon
Musk yeah nothing did you hear how he
was talking about the whole idea of
neural link yes when they attach it to
your brain basically his whole thing is
like your brains a computer right and so
let's say you're a quadriplegic it's
literally your brain is
trying to move your arms but it can't so
instead you can use bluetooth to get the
muscles to move based on your brain
right you can basically kind of
circumvent that the issues those are if
there's a like impulses like electric
pulses yes they're not the quality and
the content yes it is what what is
thought what is feelings what is
knowledge it's all it's all electrical
impulses yes your brain is just a
computer it's oh it's a it's basically a
biological circuit board okay but so
here's where it gets crazy
that technology one day in the future
could literally Google could just be
there so rather than having to say like
huh I can't remember Scottie P's last
name instead it'll just you'll know who
is the second best player in the Chicago
Bulls in 1993 you're not gonna need
don't work that's horrible
no you're gonna have all the knowledge
in the world right at your fingertips I
think we should all be learning well
that's because humans are dumb and in
the future we're gonna be smart the
second thing it means that your your
brain could potentially be programmed
which is a whole thing around the ethics
of brain interfaces are you ready for
that world I'm interested in that world
did you like the part where you said
that in the future our brains we can
actually have technology embedded in our
brains so and it'll be inked together
will they'll be connected and we won't
have to talk to each other you'll just
be able to read my mind not read yours
yes here we were watch well I'll wait
I'll wait till the last dance to bring
this up all right let's get the Tesla
speaking of Elon Musk
Tesla bang bang he ain't playin Elon
still salty this time at California he
is saying he is suing California why is
he's claiming they have no rational
basis for shutting down his factory uh
tangental e correct but there's one
nuance they shut down his factory he was
not happy about it but they did shut
down they now Alameda County has
basically said hey we're gonna start
reopening some businesses Tesla put a
plan in place to reopen but they got
told by Alameda County no you can't do
that hmm and he finally broke and said
I'm sue
you he actually filed the complaint in
federal court saying this is why he's a
SAP
he said two things that were really
important he said one the person making
this decision is a health care
professional that's not an elected
official it's somebody who was just
appointed who the hell is this person
right idiot
most likely doesn't understand economy
doesn't understand business he's just
some doctor or healthcare professional
who again is not elected by the people
but he's trying to enforce a non
constitutional thing on his business
that's first of all second of all he
said listen if you guys aren't gonna let
us operate our business I'm leaving and
he now has pledged that he's going to
pull their operations out of California
he's gonna move it to Texas or Nevada
and he's gone he's done and that's a big
loss for California of course California
he employs 35,000 people at a higher
than normal
wages so 35,000 jobs are about to leave
California second best part about this
is that there's a California
Assemblywoman which is like the state
government basically she literally
tweeted after all this happened and she
said eff you on [ __ ] you on mas right
here there you can see right there in
the thing and of course when you say
that there's two reaction three
reactions some people like that she said
it as you can see even on musk who
responded with message to receipt why
he's just like I hear you that's fine
right
but the third one the most important
thing is this is a cap this is a
California representative who's been
elected to office who is there to serve
the people she works for Elon Musk she
works for Tesla she works for the people
of California they pay taxes so that she
can draw a salary and the way that she's
treating who is one of the largest
employers in California most likely
she's not helping keep them there most
people would compete to have Tesla come
to their state instead she's literally
throwing her middle finger up at the CEO
of one of us horn they just I cannot be
a CEO because I would not react that
well to that kind of tweet what would
you say someone's not being nice to
their friends but all of this brings
together the idea that we are seeing the
true colors of people right now
right they don't care
about people it's all about the likes
and I tweets on Twitter is not actually
about keeping 35,000 jobs in Caliphate
in from the mindset that a big part of
her constituents he probably doesn't
like Elon Musk because he's rich because
he's a billionaire whatever so she's
appealing to those people versus you
know unless he so here here's two great
stats one Tesla 35,000 jobs right that
are gonna leave California now that's a
huge part of the work force on a per
single company second of all 54% of
California state budget is paid for by
the taxes of rich tech people fifty-four
more than half of the state's budget
comes from taxing the rich I'm willing
to bet that Elon Musk personally is
responsible for probably I'm gonna guess
one to two percent of California state
budget
Yvonne must pays in taxes think about
that for a second that's a lot it's wild
that they are treating somebody like
this and on top of all of this imaginary
world where the United States of America
the land of the free people want to go
to work they're trying to go to work and
the government is stepping in it's in
you cannot go to work
these people are clowns let literally
who is this woman
it's clown town that they're doing this
clown town you heard of here first
we've got unelected officials it's all a
power grab it's all about how can I
further my political standing rather
than how do I actually help my state and
my country return back to normal because
it's not like they're saying hey we're
gonna bring all of our employees back
and you can just go wild they're saying
we're gonna bring them back in a safe
orderly intelligent way we have things
in place masks social distances
especially something like a Tesla
factory I'm guessing there is room to
socially distance no I think I believe
in this to be true more than half of the
factory is robots this is crazy all
right let's keep going before I go and
find this lady I'm gonna go tweeted this
link
he also hit oh he hit this guy with some
guy was like talking [ __ ] to Ilan and
Ilan blocked them and the guy like
screenshot it and tweeted out and was
like Elon Musk billionaire can't take a
little [ __ ] on Twitter or something and
Elon responded just cuz no I think
you're really [ __ ] boring now when
people come at me on Twitter or
something I'll just respond with message
received okay eighty million Chinese men
may already be out of work nine million
more will soon be competing for jobs -
do you think this is that article I read
it um yes it's very bad why I mean this
is a complete blow to the economy right
why what are you I'm calculating in
there go ahead because I mean it's it's
it's a little bit of foreshadowing for
the u.s. to see what's going on in China
after they've kind of started reopening
after there are out on the other side of
the coronavirus and we're sitting here
looking at them and we're like oh my god
the future does not look great I don't
think this number matters why two pieces
180 million Chinese at a 1.5 billion
they literally have 10x more people in
their workforce it's an order of
magnitude larger workforce than we do
right we've got 156 million Americans in
an American workforce
I don't think actually 1.5 billion is
their total reverse there's your total
population but they have materially more
people have to know the workforce the
workforce number right so let's say it's
just half let's say it's 750 million
people right which would put them at
multiples of us at 80 million and we
have over 30 million like they're
actually doing pretty well compared up
so it says the full scale of how many
people have lost their jobs in the
country is hard to capture so it may be
more but it's still really terrifying so
there's four or five percent
unemployment rate we technically are
three to maybe four times higher than
they are on the percentage basis as of
right now another data point that's
really interesting I wrote about today
it's called the dead cat bounce fat cat
fat cat that's the guy from versatile no
his name is big cat he's not fat cat his
name is big cat I like oh man alright so
the dead cat bounces basic
right now if you think of there's been
economic data has been falling off a
cliff 4.8% GDP down in q1 of this year a
lot of people think it's gonna be worse
than q2 because everyone's sitting at
home get people back to work safely but
when they reopen these economies
everyone's gonna rush out right they're
gonna go stand in lines they're gonna
buy stuff whatever and it's gonna give
this false positive of oh everything's
back to normal right all of this data
looks like people coming back and
spending the problem with that is it's
not gonna be sustainable so everyone's
gonna rush out and move on China
basically in Week five they started to
see economic activity tick back a week
by reopening in week 9 it peaked at
almost the exact same level pre-pandemic
but now I think week 11 or 12 they're
20% lower than they were pre-pandemic
so basically we're gonna get you're
gonna get this recovery and then you're
gonna get it settle on kind of a new
normal that new normal is likely to be
ten to thirty percent lower than it was
previously
can I ask why it's called the dead cat
bounce well first of all you can ask
whatever you would like this is half
your show now seventy percent all right
dead cat bounce is because if a cat's
dead and you drop it on the floor it
literally bounces no that's why it's
called a dead cat back I don't like that
okay what do you want to call it
something live cat bounce anything but
the live cat bounce a lot the cats
always land on their feet you know that
yeah yeah they're like super athletic
like that but dead cats don't dead cats
bounce okay I also just for the record I
feel like a fat cat would bounce more
than what it does it has more things to
absorb the energy shock from the ground
just saying go ahead last dance has last
dance
okay so lasted oh my god that calendar
last dance I got things to do people to
see places to be let's go well at 11
o'clock last dance
we watched the documentary again last
night I think there's only one more
weekend but let me just paint a picture
episodes 6 & 7 7 neuro 7 & 8 ok I think
yeah so basically so my dad is really
bad about this every time we watch a
movie he talks through the entire thing
and you're like please
stop talking and you ball but I don't do
that I just want you to know I only
sometimes do that and when I ask a
question but I don't talk through the
whole thing we should have labeled this
section lunch money confessionals
because right now you're hearing a
confession of a criminal literally
you're a criminal you're watching a
movie or documentary and every five
seconds it's like it and you just you're
asking me a question you're doing
something and I can't pause it normally
I just pause and then we talk and then I
play it again but when it's on
television
I can't pause it and therefore I have to
finally guys this is what I had to
resort to just like commercial break
just hit her with the finger commercial
break
commercial break when told your
questions write them in your notes so he
kept hearing like Spike Lee this Spike
Lee that and I was like it's Mike play
in the NBA do you know who Spike Lee is
yes he is a filmmaker do you know how
tall Spike Lee is no news flash he's
real short he's not okay but that other
guy was real short is he
BJ Armstrong yes yeah you actually don't
know this new Muggsy Bogues is Muggsy
Bogues was like a business like a
professional NBA player who by NBA
standards was a [ __ ] like so me you
should taller yeah he was probably like
I don't know exactly I was but he's
probably my guess is he was five five
oh I'm taller yeah so he's like your
height plan an NBA know I'm taller maybe
he was five six
he was real short but he was good yeah
he's pretty good and also everyone knew
who he was design was Muggsy Bogues
because the last dance was fantastic
what was your favorite part about last
night even though you were half watching
and have asking questions don't uh wait
what did I like you don't even remember
what you oh oh oh I loved it when my guy
Toni Kukoc scored that last thing can
you do that your jump shot of course
again when you get the last shot one
Scottie Pippen refused to go and get off
the bench yes frickin Scottie Pippen I
have a problem with his attitude why
because you're playing a game people are
counting on you
not you get off yo ass and you go play
you're probably not wrong you know my
favorite part is Michael Jordan holds
grudges oh my god he's yeah
did you catch the part where he made up
grudges to hold yes nice game son yeah
you know you know why plena knows what
that is like cuz she does that to me
sometimes she just makes things up to be
mad about you don't do that why are you
laughing right now because there's
always a reason that may be hidden under
the surface where listen yeah yeah well
that's fun this is important now that we
are at lunch money confessionals I want
to have everyone understand yesterday
there was a crime that occurred inside
of our apartment where after we got them
watch the documentary pointa been
sitting on the couch with a blanket we
got up go brush our teeth and suck you
ready for bed and all of a sudden she
walks back in the living room and starts
getting upset that the blanket is not
put away and I had a reminder well I'm
not here to clean up after you not for
all the ladies watching if we start
splitting tasks of oh I'm only gonna do
my the things that I leave around and my
favorite thing to say in our house is
when something gets left around
I just say oh I wasn't done with that
yet why is that why did I put that plate
in the sink I wasn't done with it yet
why is that cup still sitting I wasn't
done with it yet like ever done all
right lunch money time what are we doing
who won Jolene Bassin you are the winner
acid Bassin underscore Jolie she said
what I learned from your show is that
you get two types of billionaires
builders and investors Elon Musk it
doesn't like investors like Warren great
show guys first show that interests me
after watching one of your episodes with
my partner I love that you're watching
it with your partner because I am a
partner oh so now you're not the boss I
thought we were partners all right deal
show me your fingernails he was real
excited to show me yesterday she painted
her nails purple all right guys listen
that's it for lunch money today well
wall she's trying to get rich the rest
of us trying to get our lunch money
right we are back in action in person no
more remote and we will talk to you guys
tomorrow